[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 78 local ambulante est
en pleine croissance l'épicerie mais
produit des yvelines bénéficient des
fonds européens elle propose notamment à
la vente ou en livraison des produits
exclusivement de saison locaux une autre
propice à la consommation responsable
qui a su attirer un nouveau public avec
la crise du coronavirus le succès ne se
dément pas avec le déconfinement
reportage à suivre dans cette émission
aussi ont vu leur activité s'accélérer
ces dernières semaines on s'intéressera
à deux autres porteurs de projets
franciliens bénéficiaires eux aussi des
fonds européens et qui propose de
nombreuses formations aux métiers du
numérique dans l'air du temps ils sont
aussi candidats au concours région star
de la commission européenne
nous en parlerons avec eux durant cette
émission enfin la fête de l'europe
c'était le 9 mai dernier l'occasion de
célébrer à travers le continent les 70
ans de la déclaration de robert schuman
déclaration historique pour la
construction européenne nous dira
philippe le guen de la maison jean
monnet située dans les yvelines
cette maison est le lieu exact dans
lequel la déclaration a été écrite en
l'europe toujours impacté au ralenti du
fait évidemment de l'aco vide de la
pandémie due qu'aux vide 19 et sur le
terrain concrètement en ile-de-france
certains projets financés en partie par
les fonds européens sont totalement à
l'arrêt d'autres ont poursuivi leur
activité à distance certains enfin en su
profiter de cette crise inédite pour
développer leurs activités
c'est le cas par exemple de l'épicerie
ambulante mais produit des yvelines
cette épicerie parcourt les routes du
département pour servir les villes et
villages en produits locaux la
marchandise la marchandise vendue elle
respecte les saisons et 100% yvelinoise
reportage sous le soleil avec adeline
jean-françois l'initiatrice de cette
démarche
son camion ranger aménagé adeline jean
françois est prête à recevoir ses
premiers clients
vous allez le parc on a été chercher
tout ramallah
et un chat mais vous avez du coup les
fourrages la crainte de la tremblère
j'ai aussi la viande
git fromages légumes fruits ou encore
biscuits dans cette épicerie installé
sur quatre roues l'ensemble de la
production et yvelinoise un pari de
proximité porté par cet ancien employé
de banque pour qui vendre ses produits
c'est avant tout défendre une manière de
consommer c'est vrai qu'en grande
surface au final on a tout ce qui est
tout ce qu on a tout temps de l'année
quad et thomas toute l'année tout ça il
faut être apprendre aux gens à vivre
avec les saisons est vraiment avec les
produits qui sont produits juste à côté
est
quelquefois à la tomate en plein hiver
on a ras-le-bol quoi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment respectée aussi cette
saisonnalité parce qu'on respecte
également la nature est dédiée
initialement à la vente à domicile
adeline a dû s'adapter pour répondre à
une demande toujours en hausse
la vente ambulante est devenu un service
apprécié des habitants des villages et
bourgs yvelinois est indispensable
partant de coronavirus j'aime bien parce
que céder
du point et puis
et puis bah
c'est petit c'est sympa et puis voilà
c'est complètement séduit presque
arrangé car mes courses et
dans les grands magasins et maintenant
je n'y vais ça fait une quinzaine de
jours qu'on était confiné moi je ne se
ressent pas en fait la baisse pour
l'instant où l'éventuel départ de
certains clients qui retournent à leurs
anciennes habitudes satisfaire les
clients mais aussi travailler avec les
producteurs du coin ils sont désormais
une trentaine à fournir adeline en
aliments chez comme l'un de ses premiers
partenaires elle vient chercher
notamment de belles fraises de saison
c'est vraiment pour défendre enfin créer
de la dynamique dans la région tout ça
permet de te faire découvrir nos
produits aussi indirectement c'est sur
c'est une vitrine on a une vitrine chez
d'ailleurs devrions deux pays fort de
son succès l'épicerie mais produit des
yvelines a pu embaucher son premier
employé il y a quelques semaines si les
bonnes habitudes prises pendant le
confinement se confirme l'offre locale
et de proximité 100% yvelinoise pourrait
encore s'élargir
ils ont eux aussi continué leurs
activités bien que à différemment
pendant la crise de projets franciliens
bénéficiaire des fonds européens
o clock est simple on sont candidats aux
concours régionaux star de la commission
européenne ce concours vise à
récompenser et à mettre en avant des
initiés initiative qui participe au
développement et au rayonnement des
régions en europe nous sommes grâce aux
technologies en liaison avec les deux
présidents de ces structures dario
spagnolo et frédéric bardeau vous
étaient respectivement président de
cloques et de simplon vos structures
sont basés en résumer grossièrement sur
les formations au numérique
racontez-nous chacun votre tour en
commençant par dario spagnolo comment se
sont passés ces derniers mois pour vous
c'est moi forcément inédit en
effectivement chez o clock
on a plutôt une organisation qui a été
pas vraiment bouleversés par cette
situation extraordinaire
d'une part parce que nous faisons de la
formation 100% en distançant télé
présentiel et d'autre part parce que je
sais o'clock les 90 salariés sont de
toute façon en télétravail tout le temps
et donc
ça n'a pas modifié notre manière de nous
organiser et d'assurer nos formations
auprès de plus de 400 personnes qui sont
formés en parallèle dans nos salles de
classe virtuelle
donc effectivement il ya deux volets un
peu principaux donc il ya l'entreprise
simplon donc les gens qui travaillaient
à simple ans donc là comment on fait un
métier de service pour le coup on est
tous passés en télétravail comme tout le
monde
voilà et on s'est mis en chômage partiel
partiel voilà puisqu'on a eu une baisse
d'activité 30% et après sur le coeur de
notre métier inquiète la formation en
présentiel enfin ça passe mal a
forcément il a fallu être un peu créatif
puisque on a à migrer de 1500 apprenant
qu'ils étaient normalement assis sur des
sur des chaises devant des tables dans
des salles de formation en distance yale
donc voilà ça s'est pas fait simplement
on a une partie des apprenants qui a eu
des difficultés à suivre à distance soit
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas d'accès
internet s'appelait qu'ils étaient mal
équipés soit parce qu'ils me manquer de
compétences pour faire ce qu'on est en
train de faire là en ce moment ça paraît
évident mais en fait ça n'est pas pour
tout le monde et mais après ça s'est
assez rapidement il ya un ordre de
bataille et la hand et confine à partir
de la semaine prochaine
alors vos activités à chacun vise à
former des personnes aux métiers du
numérique pour o'clock les formations se
passe à distance pour simple on vous
fait encore vous le pari de la présence
physique pour former vos apprenants
quelle que soit la méthode on le
comprend du fait de l'actualité vous est
à la mode
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment de
sortir renforcés dans vos convictions
après ces semaines de confinement et
cette reprise très progressive
il ya plusieurs volets en fait qui nous
qui nous font penser que la formation
aux métiers du numérique et en parallèle
la formation à distance aux métiers du
numérique a beaucoup d'avenir devant
devant elle c'est parce que d'une part
le dire de la démultiplication des modes
de collaboration à distance fait qu'on a
de plus en plus besoin de services
numériques et donc de développeurs pour
les pour les mettre en oeuvre et d'autre
part le fait de pouvoir former à
distance ça permet de casser la fracture
géographique qui ne permet pas de suivre
des formations de bonne qualité si on
n'habite pas dans des grandes villes ou
dans des grandes agglomérations avec la
formation à distance et lé présentiel
que nous faisons chez o clock
on a la possibilité de se former depuis
n'importe où et donc c'est évidemment
c'est un gros avantage
on le pensait avant l'arrivée de la
crise évidemment et puis la crise nous
nous nous laisse penser que les choses
vont continuer pas tout à fait de la
manière dont ça a commencé en tout cas
parce que il ya eu un phénomène
d'urgence et donc il ya eu beaucoup
d'acteurs qui se sont lancés dans la
formation à distance sans forcément
avoir pris le temps de bien mettre en
place une organisation autour de ça ce
qui était un autre cas avant mais
maintenant on voit que les choses vont
continuer avec je pense plus de rigueur
plus d'organisation plus de réflexion
aussi en amont et ça c'est très
important pour pas perdre en qualité
pas perdre en qualité par rapport aux
formations qui qui se passait très bien
en présentiel et qu'ils doivent
continuer à se passer aussi bien à
distance en classe virtuelle en télé
présentiel ce confinement à démontrer
quoi que la fracture numérique était
vraiment la chose la pire qui pouvait
exister en plus des autres inégalités
donc là c'est vrai que donner des
compétences numériques à des gens ça
appareil vraiment le le truc d'actualité
en revanche là où c'est compliqué c'est
que donner des compétences numériques à
distance par le numérique
on voit bien que colas est pas possible
donc c'est vrai que ça nous a aussi bien
confirmé sur l'idée que que pour que les
gens prennent confiance avec le
numérique qu'il faut qu'il soit en face
à passer il faut qu'on les accompagne en
vrai et que toutes les histoires qu'on
nous raconte sur les mots coup sur le
télétravail qui serait complètement
naturel à tout le monde
on voit bien que ça pose aussi des
questions donc effectivement on est on
ressort à la fois renforcer et en même
temps encore plus confirmés sur les
fondamentaux qu'on a c'est à dire
l'inclusion du maximum de gens dans la
sphère numérique est aussi l'idée que
c'est vraiment par le présentiel et par
quelque chose de non numériques qu'on
peut amener les gens dans le numérique
votre actualité c'est aussi votre
participation au concours régional de la
com
si européenne pourquoi vous lancez vous
dans ce concours
est ce que c'est une opportunité pour
vous de vous développer sur le continent
sherbrooke on est très content d'avoir
reçu le soutien de l'union européenne et
à ce titre ça nous semblait une évidence
de participer à ce concours qui nous
permettait de valoriser les projets que
nous menons grâce grâce au financement
de l'union européenne et et je dirais
que chez o clock nous avons à la fois
une chance et puis un challenge à
relever il une chance c'est de pouvoir
aider un très grand nombre de personnes
sans avoir besoin d'être physiquement
implantée dans chaque ville où nous
intervenons et le challenge à relever
c'est quelque part d'être d'être visible
et que notre action soit reconnu et
connu tout simplement de la part des
différents acteurs
que ce soient des acteurs
institutionnels ou des entreprises
donc pour nous le concours et jeux star
c'est avant tout une occasion de faire
connaître cette initiative ces
initiatives que nous portons le succès
qu'elle rencontre et peut-être espérer
avoir une une reconnaissance officielle
et en tout cas ne serait ce que le le
fait de participer c'est déjà pour nous
une grande aventure
effectivement le l'échelon européen il
est très important à sans plomb depuis
presque 2015
on a des partenaires et des présences
dans cinq pays européens et on a
commencé assez rapidement sur les
financements européens qui se déroule en
france comme sur des financements
européens de type erasmus plus à
s'intéresser à cet échelon là parce
qu'en fait on a exactement les mêmes
problèmes dans tous les pays d'europe
avec le chômage des jeunes la fracture
numérique lui aussi le manque
d'inclusion des femmes dans le numérique
donc c'est vrai qu'on a découvert via
les financements européens et viano nos
partenariats les dans les pays européens
pas mal de projets qui sont assez aligné
avec nous mais qui sont assez différents
aussi parce que chaque environnement
juridique et chaque pays est différent
donc ça nous intéresse beaucoup de
creuser ces aspects là et on avait
candidaté il ya deux ans je crois sur un
programme aussi une valorisation de d'un
no nano dispositif qui s'appelle aqueuse
qu'il ya une formation 100 % féminine
réservé aux femmes
et ça nous avait donné pas mal de
visibilité donc c'est vrai que voilà le
numérique a pas de frontières les là
plusieurs inégalités non plus donc ça
nous semble être une bonne une bonne
façon de rencontrer d'autres projets et
valoriser les nôtres merci à tous les
deux pour vos réponses et bon courage à
vous pour le concours européen
regiostars les vainqueurs choisi par des
universitaires et le public recevront
leur prix en octobre prochain
l'histoire aura retenu cette déclaration
comme l'acte fondateur de l'europe
moderne il y à 70 ans le 9 mai 1950
précisément le ministre français robert
schuman posait les bases de la
construction européenne en proposant à
la france et à l'allemagne d'unir leurs
forces dans l'industrie du charbon et de
l'acier
la déclaration de robert schuman comme
on la nomme aujourd'hui a été
entièrement écrite dans les yvelines
dans la maison président est précisément
de jean monnet à bazoches sur guyonne il
aura fallu 9 version différente du texte
pour que les auteurs se mettent d'accord
mais alors qui est robert schuman
pourquoi cette déclaration at elle tant
marqué l'histoire les explications de
philippe le guen coordinateur adjoint de
la maison jean monnet
d'abord il faut comprendre qu'il est
originaire de lorraine
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est né bon au
luxembourg mais dont son père est parti
tout de suite vivre en lorraine qui à
l'époque était allemande et donc il a
commencé sa carrière comme avocat en
allemagne et puis ensuite la lorraine
après la première guerre mondiale est
redevenue française et et bien il a eu
une carrière d'homme politique en france
il représentait le département de la
moselle comment en tant qu'un des
députés à l'assemblée nationale à
l'époque et c'est quelqu'un qui a qui
était très intègre qui était assez
respecté qui était avec de fortes
convictions catholiques
il représentait beaucoup de mouvements
catholiques mais pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale il a eu évidemment des
désaccords avec le régime de vichy il a
été même emprisonné par la gestapo et il
a réussi à s'évader il s'est caché dans
différents monastère jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre où dans le gouvernement
premier gouvernement de gaulle il a
retrouvé un siège de ministre et il a
toujours été au gouvernement ensuite il
est en 1950 il est après avoir été
président du conseil
il est ministre des affaires étrangères
à cette époque
[Musique]
la déclaration en fait exprime un projet
un projet que robert schuman avait
de recherche est déjà un projet pour le
pour l'europe pour notamment pour la
question de l'allemagne puisque dans
l'est en 1950 la toute jeune république
fédérale d'allemagne de l'ouest qui a un
an pose encore question au niveau
international en particulier les
américains voudraient qu'elles soient
ancrés vraiment du côté je dirais
occidental et robert schuman à cette
époque rencontre jean monnet qui est
commissaire au plan et qui lui a depuis
longtemps ce projet qui consiste à
mettre en commun le charbon et l'acier
franco allemand un projet très très
ambitieux et donc la déclaration schuman
finalement c'est l'expression c'est la
déclaration qui lance ce projet alors
qui donnera ensuite la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier un
an plus tard donc un an après la
déclaration schuman le traité de paris
qui instaure la communauté la première
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier est lancé dans ce texte on
retrouve les principes qui conduisent
encore aujourd'hui l'union européenne
d'abord on y dit de dans le préambule
même dit dès le premier paragraphe du
texte
c'est un objectif de paix sur le
territoire de l'europe
ensuite on met en commun à l'époque ce
qu'on a le plus précieux charbon et
l'acier mais on le met aussi sous le
contrôle d'une autorité supranationale
donc ce qui va donner ensuite la
commission européenne c'est l'ancêtre de
la commission européenne donc dans ce
texte et et fondateur aussi parce que on
y parle d'un mot fondamentale qui
aujourd'hui revient beaucoup sur toutes
les lèvres
c'est la solidarité puisque schumann
nous dit eh bien ce projet entre les
pays membres va créer une solidarité de
fait entre les pays
et ça c'est très important voilà et donc
on revient aujourd'hui 70 ans plus tard
vraiment aux fondamentaux
[Musique]
vous trouverez toujours des gens pour
dire que bon soin et on n'a pas fait
assez soi que ces trous mais on peut
dire globalement que les regarder 70 ans
plus tard nous sommes maintenant 27 à
l'époque ils n'étaient que six donc et
il ya encore des gens qui frappent à la
porte donc c'est ce projet reste
attractif même si certains souhaitent le
sang a les bons mais écoutez ça arrive
c'est ce principe peut être aujourd'hui
on a fait beaucoup de choses en commun
c'est ce principe peut-être de la
solidarité qui aujourd'hui est à est à
relancer et on l'a vu le mot a été
employée par madame von der leyen la
solidarité et je crois que c'est
justement aujourd'hui 70 ans plus tard
quand on fait une analyse de ce texte
est ce que cette solidarité de fait
réellement existe alors on l'a vu elle
existe dans certains domaines mais
aujourd'hui on peut s'interroger quand
on voit certains pays de manière
unilatérale fermer leurs frontières pu
les rouvrir faire un peu ce qu'ils
veulent quand on a en recherche des
solutions financières communes à la
crise
duco vide il a il ya une solidarité
entre les plus riches et les éléments
riches qui doit s'exercer
donc c'est cette solidarité dont parlait
robert schuman et elle est aujourd'hui
vraiment de plus en plus d'actualité
est ce que nous sommes capables de la
mettre en oeuvre et l'histoire retiendra
également cette crise inédite que nous
sommes encore en train de traverser pour
son impact économique évidemment son
impact social et sa réalité beaucoup
plus morbide celle des chiffres en
europe près de cent soixante deux mille
personnes sont décédées du coronavirus
depuis le 1er janvier et 1 million 400
mille personnes ont été testés positifs
positive parmi les pays les plus touchés
la grande bretagne avec près de 38 mille
victimes l'italie la france et l'espagne
tous les trois autour des trente mille
victimes du coronavirus on termine cette
émission par le plan de la commission
européenne dévoilée ce mercredi 26 mai
pour l'après
rona virus justement un plan historique
tomber un an tout juste après les
élections européennes de 2019 750
milliards d'euros qui autorise notamment
l'institution à lever des fonds sur les
marchés c'est une première si ce plan
n'est pas encore totalement arrêté avec
d'âpres discussions en perspective en
perspective entre les états membres
durant les prochaines semaines
il n'a pas manqué de faire réagir les
eurodéputés des yvelines pour mathilde
andrew et et le rassemblement national
c'est je cite une tartufferie au service
du projet européiste pour
françois-xavier bellamy élus des
républicains ceux qui veulent
ressusciter le vieux rêve fédéraliste à
travers un endettement commun de l'union
européenne prépare en réalité les
tensions de demain enfin pour mounir
satouri élus écologistes
il salue lui l'ambition de 40 milliards
d'euros destiné au fonds pour une
transition juste clefs de l'europe
d'après qu'on attend fin de citation
enfin aussi de cette émission retrouver
l'ensemble des modules et reportages du
7-8 europe sur notre site tv 78 et nos
réseaux on se retrouve très vite pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le